your pain will help Define you and some
people stay stuck in that pain and
continue to Loop that pain over and over
again and others realize this is your
chance to serve others that we're all
looking for purpose we want to feel like
today is going to matter we want to wake
up and do something that's going to
serve somebody else humans are hardwired
to serve they did functional MRIs on
people's brains and serving others hits
the same part of the brain as having
food and having sex it'ss literally
hardwired into you that you want to
serve and help and so having selfish
goals to yourself is not enough if you
woke up every day and felt like today is
not going to matter that's the path to
to unhappiness to depression to Suicide
where if you felt like today is going to
matter and maybe not to the world but
it'll matter to a couple people if I
show up or not that's the path to
fulfillment and happiness and that's
where I'm trying to drive people to
because we've all had painful moments in
our life hey it's EV Carmichael and I
watch these videos every day because I
need them for motivation being around
successful entrepreneurs every morning
helps me believe that I can do great
things too it's like your morning coffee
but for or your goals kickstarting your
day with a blast of positivity so here
is a challenge for you try watching One
video every morning for the next 30 days
and let's find out together if they help
you do great things too if you're in
leave a hash believe in the comments
below so I can celebrate with
you when you think about how do you find
your purpose well there's so many great
causes why pick one cause or another was
because you have a personal attachment
to it so I want to solve what I think is
the world's biggest problem people don't
believe in themselves enough and I do it
by helping entrepreneurs I think
entrepreneurs are going to solve all the
world's problems it's not government
it's not big business is go to the
entrepreneurs whether I'm right or wrong
that's the thesis that I operate through
and I want to help entrepreneurs believe
in themselves more because my biggest
problem was and still is a lack of
belief in myself to get to the next step
and so as much as I'm the Bel guy my
biggest problem is still I don't believe
in myself to do the next big thing I
believe in myself to do what I've done I
could do that again again and again and
again but to do the next big thing is
where I lack belief and so I still need
it myself I think we all need it and so
that's what I'm trying to create for the
world on a daily basis and so if you
think about for everybody watching what
was the most painful moment in your life
when did you feel completely worthless
and you may not be completely out of
that now but you're way ahead of where
you used to be and you know if that was
10 years ago you could go back and talk
to the youu from 10 years ago and give
them some really Sage advice on what to
do
and then recognize that there are
millions of people right now who
currently are who you used to be and
they need your help you know they could
use your words of wisdom and they'll
listen to you where they won't listen to
Evan carmichel or Marty clay or opo
Winfree or somebody else but they'll
listen to you because you've been
through the same thing that they are
going through right now rule number two
is focus on who you serve people ask me
when they see this the number one
question I get asked is well how did you
keep going you know like how did you
keep going when it wasn't working out
it's great to see the 3 million whatever
right now but how did you keep going and
the answer for me was it's always about
serving so it was never about what I
don't have it was always a focus on who
I am serving right now and we tend to
always focus on what we don't have yet
right like why am I not at a th000 subs
or 10,000 subs or 100,000 subs or a
million or like whatever the next step
is for you where if you focus on who you
are serving right now one you're a lot
happier you know two the people who you
are serving they'll take you to the
people who you're not serving yet and it
also gives you the momentum and the
energy and encouragement to keep going
everybody in this room has watched a
video on YouTube and it inspired them
inspired you to make some kind of shift
right you've all watched some video from
somebody on YouTube that then inspired
you to make some kind of shift and
that's what I see in this room you guys
have the ability to be that person for
somebody else in default to assuming
that a 40 people watched your video we
all we all we always think oh 40 people
that sucks right assume that for one out
of those 40 people this was the
lifechanging message that they needed to
hear and if you can remember that while
you're in the filming process it changes
everything because we're so focused on
how well we look and how good our
microphone and camera and the setup and
all of that is if you focus and said on
I'm going to make something today that's
going to change somebody's life maybe
not a million people but one person
who's watching this video they're going
to have their life change because you
showed up that day rule number three is
be clear make it clear what you do one
of the biggest challenges that a lot of
entrepreneurs have when you're creating
content is like we know what we do but
does our audience know what we do so
here's another great example Another
Movie Maker Jill Collins she has her
Channel Jill Collins connections again
she's making content 4 days ago 11 days
ago two weeks ago 3 weeks ago so she's
staying in the minimum of once a week
that would would be my recommendation
for everybody once a week means you're
in the game if you're asking how many
videos should I make at least once a
week that gets you in the game so she is
doing that plus a little B more so
that's great when I come to the page so
I don't really know what she's about so
Jill Collins okay she looks successful
she's got her logo she looks like she's
a somebody and she's comfortable in
front of the camera and she's done some
photo shoots great but I don't know what
connections plus means I'm not sure what
this channel is about now I know Jill
obviously because she's in mov makers
and I've I've learned about her business
but I'm coming through the lens of I've
never heard of you before and this is
what you want to assume when people are
coming to your channel they have never
heard of you before you are not making
videos for your mom you're making videos
for people who have no idea who you are
it's your first time being exposed to
your brain and so we want to show them
what we're about so I don't know what
she's about from this Banner from the
avatar from the name I don't know what
she does if I go back to here he does
investor financing now I would put his
name somewhere here right I don't now he
went maybe too far in the opposite
direction he like this guy's name is Bo
it doesn't say that anywhere right but
it's talking about investor financing we
look at Dan Dan's telling me about how
to do wise money tools he's a financial
expert a speaker author investor
business owner right he helps people uh
discover how to build their wealth
exponentially right so I get a sense of
who Dan is and what he's about when I
come to Jill's page I don't know what
she's about yet and so what what that
means is you're requiring the user to go
do extra work and so we don't want to
have to make them do extra work we want
them to instantly understand what it is
that we do rule number four is build
self-belief if you want to race against
three-year-olds you wouldn't care like
who you don't celebrate that because
it's easy but when you do something
that's hard and just the willingness to
try something that's hard that's how you
start to build self-belief and
self-confidence so the fact that I went
live for five minutes with a broken neck
and concussion meant more than all the
other lives that I did on the whole trip
and I told my agent like how you doing
how you feeling he's like well I can't
even like I can't even get dressed by
myself you know like I I get out of bed
I Nina my wife had to help him with
everything help me get out of bed help
me go to the bathroom help me put my
clothes on and he starts laughing at
me like Steve I'm glad you find like I
don't know how you find this funny yeah
I'm in like insane pain here why are you
laughing dude he's like I'm sorry man
sorry you got to film this like what do
you mean I got to film this I want you
to go live and show your morning routine
it's like Steve I'm like half naked
Nina's carrying me around and my my my
wife is this you know little five foot
something you know Chinese woman you
know she's like I'm six foot two she's
it's a lot of work uh you got to film
that whole thing and immediately I'm
thinking oh my God this is this is not
great right I mean I've gained some
weight now because I'm not being very
active I'm still suffering from a
concussion and not being myself um but
whatever like okay let's film it so the
next morning I woke up and I did an
Instagram live of my whole morning
routine and Nina helping me get ready
and and all of it just to just to
conquer the fear just to say to myself
that I did it because that's how you
build self-belief if you're afraid to
start a podcast great start a podcast
just to do it just to tell yourself that
you can do it you're afraid to ask ask
whoever your hero's Grant Cardone
message him and say I'd love to have you
on my podcast right he may never see it
he may say Marty I hate your face like
who knows actually grants he's for all
of his bravado and everything he's
actually a pretty good guy um but
whatever you never know like whatever
whatever the voice is in our head to
tell us we can't do it cool the more you
listen to that voice the more you're not
going to take the actions that would
make yourself proud so even if the the
most likely outcome is rejection or
failure you still do it to show yourself
that you're capable also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the workshe designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five is fix your
environment I'm one of these crazy guys
that I mean I always love that kind of
stuff I just you know it just kind of
wakes you up and you're like okay I get
a little adrenaline shot but sometimes
it's hard to get people to believe that
it really is just what you just said
which is to believe yeah I think
people's environment sucks I put it down
to environment man I think it starts
with self-awareness like knowing what
you want to do the book is called your
one word so knowing what your one word
is is really an exercise in
self-awareness but once you find it it's
the environment people may come across
your podcast Michael and say man that
that Michael's amazing had this great
idea and they go off and they're working
for the rest of the day hustling hard
and then they wake up the next day and
that drive and motivation is gone
because their environment sucks cuz
their environment keeps pulling them
back down to where they were before and
so you need to whatever you have that
big vision for yourself whatever is like
I want to be the most successful Trader
in the world okay great you need to
start your day every day with resources
like read some of Michael's book or
listen to the podcast or watch an
interview or whatever it is to get you
in that mindset that you can go and
accomplish that big thing because too
often the next day you're going to wake
up and everything's gone rule number six
is build your brand we want a consistent
thumbnail design so here I'm looking at
another movement maker Bo Xin he has
been crushing it with his show and
bringing in deals he just landed another
deal that was 30 or $40,000 as a result
of having a guest on his show so
something we teach inside the movie
makers program is to do a BISD show
think about the people that if they knew
who you are would lead to revenue for
you and then start a show and have them
come on so you build a relationship so
he's been crushing that generating tons
of money doing it but what I want to
talk about with his channel is a
consistent thumbnail design so if you
look at his videos you can see he's
consistent this man is pumping out
content two days ago
uh 3 days ago 3 days ago four days ago
he also suffers from being too short
right so the the content should be much
longer two minute video two minute video
five minute video it's gonna be really
hard to get these videos ranking uh but
we've already talked about that so the
key thing for him is consistent
thumbnail design so the thing he has
going for him is he is in every
thumbnail a lot of times it's that
similar kind of LinkedIn profile picture
that you see everywhere but what you
want people to do is instantly know that
it's your thumbnail so what does a bow
thumbnail look like so in His Banner
he's using you know this blue and he's
got this kind of aqua color and if
that's your color and that's your F make
that consistent because it's so much
easier for people to see the videos one
of the main ways to grow your channel is
through suggested if you look at the big
channels you look at someone look at
Alex and I was growing it's through
suggested right it's not through search
we think of YouTube as the world's
second largest search engine and it is
but most of the growth from the big
channels come from suggested in side of
education and thought leadership what
that means is when I load one of your
videos and I'm watching
this I want to see your video showing up
down the
side and this is where a lot of the
views will come and so every time you're
looking at one video then most people
even if they start with a search they
don't go back to the search results they
start going down the rabbit hole what
gets recommended to them and so this is
where you want to be showing up so the
challenge with a thumbnail design that's
all over the place even this one like
this one's done okay for Alex this is
not a great thumbnail for him because
you can't see Alex's face and so if I'm
skipping through this quickly I see Dave
Ramsey I don't necessarily instantly
recognize that that's Alex and so I
might pass it over even if I'm
subscribed to the channel even if I love
Alex and what he's all about because the
thumbnail design is way off and it's
hard to instantly know that that's him
compared to I know that this is Patrick
B David I know that this is Tony Robins
I know that this is Tom Bilu you know
even Gary Gary could do a better job do
I know instantly that that's Gary ve no
and if I'm seeing it on the phone it's
going to be even smaller so harder to
see so Gary needs to fix his thumbnails
Alex needs to fix his thumbnails they
would get more suggested views it's the
same problem that B has here if I watch
you know if I see this and I look at
this and that's B and I get this color
and font and layout and like I know that
this is what they're all about cool if I
see this video and I click on it and
then I'm watching it and then I see this
one show up down the side does that is
that bow I don't know it it looks like a
different guy and he's not in his suit
and it's a different font and it's a
different color scheme and so I might
watch this video and love it but then I
see this one down the side or I see this
one down the side or I see this one down
the side and because they all look
completely different I may not click on
the video so he was losing people who
want to click on his videos but they
don't instantly recognize him and so
that's what we want to do is we we want
to create a brand this is not anything
new to YouTube you want to have a brand
that is identifiable why do companies
spend so much on logos and fonts and
assets because it means something
because you want people to instantly
recognize you rule number seven is take
the first step the hardest step is the
first step you know like once you start
your first video it's easier to do
another video and another video but once
you start moving it's easier to just to
stay in momentum than to to go from
nothing to that first step and similar
to your story a lot lot of people sit on
an idea they take six years to take the
first
step and then when they take the first
step they just keep going it's just like
just don't wait six years next time take
six minutes and just start right and so
one of the things that I love to try to
do is go from idea to action so when you
get an idea just do some small version
of it just get started I had an idea for
a podcast when I was driving through I
was on my tour in
2019 and I'm driving through the desert
in Texas and I had this idea to start a
podcast with my friend Mark drer and why
am I thinking about Mark in Texas all of
a sudden I hadn't talked to him for a
while and why do I want to start a
podcast with them normally it would be
overanalyzing judging thinking I don't
have time to do this right now I'm on
tour I got a million things I have to do
I'll do this when I get back to Toronto
in in another eight weeks right it's
like there's no time to do this right
now but I've taught myself to do the
opposite that idea to action so uh I'm
driving my wife Nina is beside me and
said Nina we need to get a hold of Mark
you know let's like let's message Mark
and so we we grab him on a call and I
told him about the idea for the podcast
like I'm in like let's do this as soon
as you get back to Toronto I'm gonna
start getting ready for preparations
it's like Mark that's two months away
man I'm not
doing by that time it's like that's like
a decade away dude I'm not waiting two
months to do this well when do you want
to start like what do you mean today
like what do you mean today like today
we're GNA I'm going to drive to get into
my Air BNB I'm going to hopefully they
have good internet and we're going to
launch the first show today it's like
but I don't even know what we're going
to call it I don't know what we're I
don't know what the first Topic's going
to be I don't know how we're going to
intro this like all the things that
start it's like well Mark I'm going to
be there in 90
minutes figur it
out and then I got to the Airbnb we
figured out the internet and we had our
first show and was it was it great no
but the most important thing was you
take the first step rule number eight is
is do split tests we need to be testing
our old videos updating the thumbnails
and titles on our old videos if you have
any kind of catalog of videos in your
YouTube account right now the single
greatest opportunity is to be split
testing the thumbnails and titles we're
so focused on what's next and we don't
do enough testing of what has come right
now we launch one main video every day
on my main Channel and we have an
internal goal to split test 100 videos
every day from our back catalog 100 new
split tests on thumbnails every day now
I'm crazy Nobody Does that right I've
got four people on my team and they're
just dedicated to doing that completely
but the single biggest opportunity if
you have any size Channel with content
on it the biggest opportunity for Gary
VE for sha for Alex heroi for Vanessa
Lao for Pat Flynn for Evan carmichel is
to split test your old content this is
an example when I was doing this I told
YouTube it's like dude this is crazy can
we do a case study on you and so they
wrote this up as a case study on me for
split testing we took a video here this
video was done in
2016 we split tested it changed the
thumbnail in 2020 now first off this
video in 2020 would still get me 100
views a day a 4-year-old video was still
get me views 100 views a day no that's
not insane but you're not getting that
on NE platform right nobody cares about
your Instagram your Tik Tok your Twitter
your Facebook your LinkedIn your
anything from a week ago let alone 4
years ago so if you're trying to build a
brand that lasts YouTube has to be the
game for you rule number nine is be
resourceful don't be limited to people
that you can actually have a
conversation with I've learned a ton
from what I call aspirational mentors
you know Steve Jobs is my mentor Walt
Disney is my mentor EP janini is my
mentor you could learn a ton from people
who've done a lot more than you this is
where people say well like I live in a
small town there's nobody for me to get
mentored by they all live in New York
City or whatever you could still learn
from those people listen to these
interviews that Michael does he's had
great people on board watch their videos
read their books you can learn a lot
from these people even if you never meet
them or if they've passed on if this was
20 years ago you wanted to be a Trader
you might have to go to Wall Street and
go find a company and learn but like how
many episodes have you done man like
hundreds of episodes yeah just go back
and listen to everything Michael has
said and all the guests had had on board
you have the access if you have a
computer with internet you have access
to the knowledge and Rule Number 10 the
last one before some very special bonus
Clips is learn about Impressions if you
look at this category for example this
is 1 to 5 million impressions so over
the past 90 days these videos got one to
five million impressions those are good
to compare against each other and you
can find this data in YouTube Studio as
well just look at the past 90 days look
at the impressions and then see how well
the videos are doing so if you look at
this category as an example this video
here has 1.7 million impressions and a
2.3% clickthrough
rate if I scroll down we see this one
here this one's doing well Elon Musk
talking about weed here we go has a
million impressions and 7% clickthrough
rate similar number of Impressions
reaching the same number of people but a
vastly different clickthrough
rate these videos are worth comparing to
each other 7% versus
2.3% is a big
difference we need to go and fix these
videos right so in this scenario in the
one to five million impressions having a
2.3% clickthrough rate is bad we have to
go in and fix it and we might work on
that thumbnail 50 times it it loses it's
still underperforming do it again test
again test again test again test
again this morning
I did my walk outside I did my yoga I
did my my stairs uh with the cold I'm
going to try a couple things one I'm
going to try wearing fewer layers when I
go outside it's becoming winter here in
Canada and it gets really cold in winter
in Canada so going to try to embrace
that a little bit more and wear a fewer
layers two I do a cold Splash every
morning so one of the first things I do
when I wake up is As I just put a whole
bunch of cold water all over my face so
I'm going to keep doing that and then
three after every workout a cold shower
so I did it this morning after my yoga
workout this morning turned on the cold
went in uh making sure to get it um on
the backs of the shoulder this is from
Tim Ferris that's where the the brown
fat really lives and comes alive um and
so making sure you get the cold water on
the backs of your shoulder the book also
quickly mentions cryotherapy where you
stand in a machine and uh it takes you
down to some crazy low temperature uh
I'm pretty sure he said that it didn't
have a ton of research he wasn't sure
how well it worked but he did it once so
you know what I'm going to look into it
too the goal of this 50-day challenge is
that how much can I do in 50 days to
expose myself to learn to get ideas to
get mentors so I'm going to also look up
Crow therapy in my town and see if I can
find something for me it is 3:24 p.m. I
am officially fasting until 6:00 p.m.
this is a
lifesaver I am so hungry but you know
what a little bit of Himalayan sea salt
and I'm good I'm good these next 2 and 1
half hours no problem we got this okay
it is 6:30 I get to eat um we're doing a
buffet for my father-in-law's birthday
so Pro side is going to be lots of
hopefully some healthy food for me to
eat downside is seeing all of the
amazing other stuff that I can't
eat but it's okay let's
go this is Nina's meal oh that looks SC
give us a definition of what is a little
man and and how you define that and
maybe how you manage to you know ignore
it defy it as you were growing your
business and your channel sure so the
little man is the hater in your life
it's the person who's telling you that
you can't do it pointing out all the
reasons why your next podcast is not
going to work or your big book or
whatever your dream is all the reasons
why it's not going to work out and often
those are people those are real people
in our lives maybe it's our parents our
friends our guidance counselor our boss
you know people in our community uh and
often it's ourselves You Know The Enemy
is is the enemy right like you are your
own enemy um and so often times we have
great big ideas that we're excited by
and then how often do we talk ourselves
down from those big Ideas after after
you sleep on it and the next day you
wake up like a I can't do that I'm to
nobody will listen to me on before you
even tell anybody else it's your your
own inner little man that is holding you
back so that's the little man and and
rule number seven it's there because
it's one of the most consistent things
that come up with big entrepreneurs and
dreamers you're doing something that is
crazy that is bold that has never been
done before and whenever you do that you
know if you're a change maker you're
doing things that have never been done
before and so you're going to get
criticism you're going to get heat both
from the outside world and the inside
world and so the two things that I find
really help me personally with that one
is just being around people who have to
deal with criticism a lot and see how
they react I think is valuable I think
as an example if you want to get more
confident better than reading a book on
eight ways to get more confident start
hanging around confident people if you
do that their mindsets their beliefs
their attitudes will rub off on you like
if you want to if you want to be a
change maker better than just
downloading some PDF with eight
different ways of how to be a change
maker hang around Jay like he is a
change maker just by hanging around him
almost regardless of what he's talking
about it's going to inspire some change
within you and the more you hang around
Jay and guys like Jay more you listen to
this podcast then the more you're going
to just be willed into making change for
yourself just like if you're hanging
around negative people all day long
you're going to become negative you're
going to complain more where if you're
hanging around big gamechanging people
you're going to start gravitating
towards that right it's a concept of you
are your your best closest friends
around you right right right right so so
that's one so if you want to avoid the
little man or or learn how to ignore him
then you need to be around people who
are dealing with big things and dealing
with criticism and chances are those
aren't currently the people in your life
they're they are other people so for me
that's where I get it from the book I
get it from the videos seeing how
somebody reacts to criticism and say huh
that's interesting I would have I would
have felt I would have taken that more
critically or I would have been hurt by
that and seen how they do it if you do
that consistently to rub off on you you
can choose at any moment positivity you
can choose at any moment gratitude you
can choose at any moment service you can
choose to change your mindset in in an
instant if you wanted to the challenge
is we're so living in our subconscious
mode that we don't we don't catch it
soon enough we don't take the action
that we're proud of and then we regret
it you know we regret it later on this
morning I woke up really early I'm very
tired I woke up at 3:45 a.m. for some
reason don't know why uh look at my look
at my watch like 3:45 a.m. what oh man
okay try to go back to sleep toss turn
for about an hour and then I got up like
okay you know what 4:45 it's almost 5
you know
let's let's get up and I got to work and
started doing things and then the the
crash hit me the crash hit me just not
enough sleep and everything inside me
wanted to shut down you know I wanted to
just take a complete break not do my
walk in the morning not not take the
dogs out well the dogs have to go out
but not do my routine not do any my
usual stuff not record videos today's a
Tuesday when I record it's video
recording day and it's in these moments
those trying times that you have to
decide who you want to be you have to
decide if you want to choose to be
positive choose to live in gratitude
choose to live in productivity choose to
live in service or not what would the
future you think of your actions right
now and I think 95% of the time the
answer is to push a little harder move
the break line forward right where where
you would normally take a break move
that forward just a little bit move the
break line forward a touch and 5% of the
time you have to be more gentle on
yourself when my family dog passed away
when I broke my neck when you know all
sorts of things have happened to me just
like they've happened to you sometimes
the answer is to give yourself a little
more grace to recognize how far you've
come everything that you've done with
the limited amount of resources and time
that you
have but I think we default to that then
we default to staying stuck and staying
small because life is going to throw so
many different challenges at you so I
think 95% of the time that's the 5%
right 5% of the time you give yourself
more grace you let yourself off the hook
you take the day off you do whatever you
need especially if you're struggling
with grief if you're struggling with
grief I think you just have to work your
way through it you have to give yourself
a lot of Grace and a lot of time and and
it will get better and and just please
don't go through it alone
but almost everything else usually the
answer is to keep
going because it'll make you more
proud because you're teaching yourself
that you stand up to obstacles then you
overcome what's the fastest way to learn
a language what's the fastest way to
learn Japanese well it's a go to Japan
sure you can read some books and and you
can hire a tutor and that the more
intense it becomes the more you're
actually living it the faster you're
going to pick it up so if you want to
develop
the mindset of the high achiever if you
want to become that person the people
that you look up to the the whoever of
the world like I want to be the next
whoever perfect that person the more you
hang around with them the more it's
going to rub off on you how they think
cuz how they think how they act how they
behave how they see the world is very
different than how you see it right now
and how the people around you definitely
see the world right now so how do you do
it how do you start to become it well I
look at what I'm doing and this was one
of my biggest challenges when I was
getting started and honestly still in
like I I think the biggest problem in
the world is a lack of belief I'm trying
to solve the world's biggest problem
people don't believe in themselves
enough I don't you don't opra doesn't
enough for the next level so how do you
start to believe in yourself more the
thing that helped me the most was to
have these successful people around me
constantly and so I want to share a few
tactics that I think can really help you
that has really helped me as being the
shy introverted kid who never wanted to
be in front of a a camera and was making
300 bucks a month and quit on my
business partner and thought life was
over right to to now here and it's taken
me 20 years to get here so hopefully we
can shorten that path for you if you
actually follow some of the advice in
this video so step number one how do we
create that environment of
Excellence what you feed into your brain
brain really really really matters so
figure out how you love to learn for me
it's videos I like to see things I need
to be visual if that's you then you need
to have a way to have those videos
coming into your life every day it could
be part of your morning routine that's
why I make this channel part of your
morning routine subscribe to the channel
every morning every weekday we got a new
video out there for you to give you the
shot of andpress that to help you but if
it's not my channel it's some other
channel one of my other channels
subscribe to the channels that make you
feel bold powerful Unstoppable give you
hope give you belief in yourself and
then watch that video every day or
listen to that podcast every day or read
that book every day the trick is it
can't be the same book or this the the
one video cuz that one video on repeat
is going to lose its Effectiveness right
you know it you watch a video gets you
all fired up and then you watch again
the next day and it's not as like oh
what happened I don't feel as good and
you watch it the next day and the
feeling's gone so you can't just read
the same book over and over watch the
same video over and over and over again
the key is to find a consistent source
so if you love this Channel or you love
this video I'm making other videos just
like this that you can subscribe to if
you like an author go find their other
books or go find the people that Inspire
them so that you can read something
every day if you like a podcast go find
other podcasts like them so you have
something every day so you you are
manipulating what comes in your head
with intention now
with intention so you're not just
scrolling through things like I am going
to watch one of these videos every day
to slowly shift myself forward cuz it'll
happen if you love Elon Musk and you
watch Elon Musk every day what will
happen is slowly day by day you will
start to think like Elon Musk it will
happen he will pull you forward you will
start to see the big difference in how
he thinks versus how the people around
you think versus how you think right now
and he will give you more courage and
more boldness and more a sense of hope
and purpose that you can do it too
you'll start to think more like him I've
heard you discuss that 80% of the
content system is getting people to have
an emotional reaction to what you create
what strategies do you have in place to
ensure your audience has an emotional
connection with your content you need to
have an emotional connection to the
content so you do an interview like how
many of these have you done on this
channel we're approaching
171 171 about 17 171 interviews okay so
like if you're going to do interviews
you better like doing interviews yeah
amen cuz you're going to be 171
interviews in and then hate your life so
for people like I'm going to start a
podcast cool but you better like talking
to people even if you're like I'm
introverted I'm shy it's not natural or
normal but I like serving and so this is
one of the ways to do it but if you
don't if you're doing it just as a
strategy you're going to lose you have
to actually be curious about people and
then you have to bring on guests who you
actually care
about right so so if you brought on a
guest who like you love their story and
you love something that they've done
then that's going to light you up and if
it lights you up it'll light up the
audience versus if they're on just for a
strategy you know if it's like I'm going
to bring on somebody to talk about
passive income because it's trending but
like you don't care about passive income
right then it's going to be the most
boring and maybe you do I don't know but
it' be the most boring interview you
know of all time and so the keys is Mak
content that you deeply connect with
that you get super excited by and your
energy will create energy for the people
watching like oh my go this guy so
excited by it I'm going to get into it
too I use the pipit watch and it tracks
my sleep and it gives me a score every
day for how well I slept and I've hit I
think 89 out of 100 as my best sleep
score and what I would love to do is to
improve my sleep score one of the best
things of having a wearable is you have
something that you can track so I want
to find a way to consistently be in the
9s and have an excellent amazing world
class sleep so on the on the first day
that I was tracking that I did not use
ear plugs I got an 88 sleep score which
is pretty good already up there uh when
I moved to the I don't have it anymore I
threw them away but I had the kind of
black just ones I think I showed earlier
in this video uh very standard just kind
of run-of-the-mill black earphone they
didn't do anything I got a 80 sleep
score but they were barely in it wasn't
really pulling anything um any of the
the audio out then I went to the
hardcore ones and these ones are amazing
these are the ones that I wore at the
Tony ramens event that I was right up
against a speaker and it really pulled
it out so if you want a good earplug
whether for sleeping or not the brand is
called Heroes Heroes but with an A so
like Heroes there's only one left in
this pack extreme protection earplugs 14
pairs NR r33 I think that means
something uh these are maze at knocking
out the sound so on the first day I got
an 84 so nothing no earplugs was 88
black earplugs kind of standard ear
plugs got an 80 these earplugs went up
to 84 so we're going in the right
direction on the first night on the
second night though it actually fell
down the
73 uh what happened was I had this in
and when I was sleeping it caught on the
side and it it jammed further into my
ear and it it hurt and it woke me up so
it didn't have as good as sleep and so I
decided you know I'm not going to wear
it I'm not going to wear it the next day
and and I haven't I haven't gone back to
it so overall I don't think earplugs are
the solution for me so I'm not going to
ongoing be using these I think the main
reason is I don't mind ambient noises
you know if something uh something broke
or something fell or there's a loud
noise a crash bang I'm going to wake up
but overall I kind of like the ambient
noises it's kind of like you know a a
sleeping machine with the white noise or
I used to fall asleep listen to sports
radio at night I like having a little
bit of noise going on so the earplugs
are not helping me improve my Sleep
Quality I don't think they're hurting
except when it IT jams into my ear and
it causes a lot of pain so I don't think
it's hurting but I don't think it's
helping me when you look at yourself in
the mirror what do you say when you
think about yourself what do you say a
lot of a lot of the stuff that we say
about ourselves we wouldn't we wouldn't
say to our worst enemies it's rough I
actually think it's great to be your own
warst critic I think it's great I think
honestly I think for a lot of people um
we're not hard enough on ourselves let
me let me stick with me for a minute
we're not hard enough on ourselves
because in order to get to where you
want to go you actually need to push
yourself more the problem is why we
can't do it is we don't love ourselves
enough we're not our biggest cheerleader
enough you have to balance those two
things we are very hard on ourselves but
because there's no self-love we're not
cheering ourselves on enough we're not
our biggest
cheerleader
you can't handle it most people are
already at the breaking point you know
like sitting here in a parking lot these
you know those I guess it's kind of
blurry you can't really see them but
people hate their lives they're barely
hanging on most people are barely
hanging on we're barely hanging on to
what we're doing we we can post all
these great things on Instagram or
wherever and make it look like we're
enjoying our life but most people are
barely hanging on the people who are
judging you for your life and telling
you that you suck hate their own lives
they are barely hanging on so how do we
get through it well yes we can be harder
on ourselves but we need to balance that
with more
self-love you have to remind yourself of
why you're great what you're proud of
what you're grateful for and it has to
be consistent otherwise you'll never get
to where you want to go and when you
love yourself more that actually allows
you to be harder on
yourself when you love yourself more and
you actually feel it you can push
yourself harder you can you can be more
um demanding of yourself because it's
not going to push you over the edge
because you're not tying yourself worth
to you accomplishing that thing and when
you don't accomplish it you feel like a
loser it's starting from a place of I'm
amazing that allows you to be way harder
on yourself most people don't get what
they want because you don't follow
through enough you just don't follow
through it's based out of insecurity you
start and stop start and stop you're
afraid of hurting people's feelings
you're afraid of what they're going to
say about you you're afraid they're
going to judge you and we're afraid of
having that L on our personal resume and
so we we stop we stop and try to do
something else where we're seeing more
immediate results but if it's your goal
if it's your dream you have to follow
through one of my favorite stories is
with Brandon bashard and I went to speak
at his event in Phoenix and I I knew of
him but I didn't know him at the time it
was his business partner that had me
come out to his event and hired me to
speak there and that's where I met
Brandon for the first time and he asked
me hey what are you working on what can
I help you what's next for you and I
said I want work on my book and he said
I'd I'd love to uh I'd love to help I'd
love to give you some feedback on your
book like I am definitely down for
that let let's connect and uh he's he
asked me what my phone number was and at
the time I didn't have a phone I didn't
use a phone uh number and I said how
about email and he said oh I'm not
really good on email but if that's the
only way then let's do email so we
exchanged emails and uh I didn't I
didn't hear from him so I I followed up
and I said hey Brendan thank you you
know great event um love to talk about
the book like you suggested and didn't
hear back and followed up couple weeks
later and didn't hear back and followed
up a couple weeks later and then uh he
said oh man thank you uh I'm I'm super
swamp right now but uh let Let's either
do come out to my place and we'll do a
jam session or got this event coming up
maybe you can come be there and said I'm
down for either which one you want to do
and didn't hear back and then wrote a
couple more messages and didn't hear
back and here's what's really important
in my head every time I sent another
email I I was questioning myself I was
judging myself like oo I don't want to
bother him um maybe maybe I'm I'm being
too overwhelming maybe maybe he doesn't
actually want me to come out uh maybe
I'm offending him maybe you know I'm not
respecting him maybe I'm asking for too
much you know that's that's the thought
in my head before every email where in
reality he's he's just a busy guy he's
he had a lot of stuff going on he had a
launch that was happening that I wasn't
even aware of uh that he was planning
behind the scenes and so he is he's you
know not crazy stressed out but he just
has a lot on his plate that he's dealing
with and it's hard to tell ourselves
that it's easier to default to the
insecurity of maybe you're bothering
maybe you're asking too much maybe
you're not worthy Maybe you should move
on the event that he talked about me
coming to was coming up and I still
hadn't heard back whether whether he
wanted me there or not or you know my
book launch was coming up too and I
thought I'm going to send one more email
just one more email that's it I'm going
to send one more email and hopefully
something happens if not then I'm done
and um hopefully you know he doesn't
think I'm a loser or
whatever and he he wrote back in the
email and like hey sorry man again I'm
not super great on email I've just been
swamped planning all the things uh yeah
come on out come out to the event speak
at the event to and that was his big
event that was you know $3 to $50,000 a
year Mastermind to be a part of that
then I spoke on stage that then at the
event after I spoke I met with him and
uh Dean graziosi backstage for an hour
over lunch and planned my entire book
strategy that then led to me getting inv
invited to go to Brendan's house uh a
couple days later and hang with him and
Dean and Tom Bilo and LS house and J
shett and Russell Brunson and all sorts
of amazing humans who built giant
businesses all of that
happened because I sent that one more
email because I followed up and I
followed up and I followed up and I
followed up and it wasn't that he hated
me or that he thought I sucked or that I
was being overwhelming or whatever that
that I I kept following up just had the
persistence there's a lot of
opportunities that are in front of you
right now that just are not happening
because there's not enough followup
there's not enough persistence I love
how fascinated you are to just learn and
take what you like from different people
and then apply it and so forth and it's
you'll never not that you need to worry
about it but you'll never get stale or
dull or repeat yourself too much cuz
you're constantly learning and applying
and then giving back it's
awesome well thank you I mean there's a
lot in there I appreciate it um really
I'm just making videos and content and
having guests on and being guests on
shows that that I'm curious about you
know I love being on with you like you
came to me through Dave and Dave said
hey I got this new guy I'm work with
Craig can you hop on an IG live together
right I didn't know who you were but
it's Dave so like okay happy to do it
right and then like we're back for round
two because round one was so good right
and so I'm not as strategic
of uh I need to do this person because
it's gonna help me grow my channel it's
more what what do I want to learn if I
just wanted to grow I should go negative
if I did the top 10 stupidest things
Kanye has said that would that'd be fire
people would love that stuff right
people but I'm trying to spread it would
make me feel gross because I want to
create optimism and belief and hope for
people imagine that 80% of the thoughts
that you've got
80% are negative we are beating
ourselves up we are telling ourselves
that we can't do things it's not even
our friends and family people around us
telling us that we suck it's us it's
ourselves we tell ourselves we're not
good enough we can't do this we're not
strong enough smart enough we're from
the wrong country we look the wrong way
you know we're too young we're too old
whatever it is 80% of our thoughts are
negative and then 95% of those negative
thoughts are the exact same negative
thoughts that we had yesterday it's no
wonder why we stay small it's no wonder
why we stay stuck because we've created
this reinforcing Loop of negativity this
is why I think the world's biggest
problem is lack of belief you I'm I'm on
a mission every day wake up try to make
content try to spread the message to
help people believe in themselves more I
think lack of belief is the single
biggest problem in the world and I also
believe that everybody has Michael
Jordan level genius at something like
you are the greatest you're the greatest
in the world at something
and it's not what you went to school for
and it's not what your parents did for
living probably it's something
completely different and you have to
have the courage to go off and Chase it
and find it and and do it
because the woman who solves cancer
should have already solved it by now but
she never believed in herself enough to
go to medical school and now she's a
manager and accounting firm which
doesn't like her life right I mean this
is this is where most of us are stuck
most people wake up and they drive to
job that that we don't like most people
are stuck and barely hanging on and do
not like their life and feel like
they're not contributing they're not
they're not making any kind of
difference they're not doing anything
meaningful or impactful at all in the
world that's most people like imagine
waking up and that's your daily reality
that may be you or that may have been
who you were and you're still
discovering and trying to improve and
get better but if 80% of those thoughts
that come through your head conscious or
unconscious are negative I think a lot
of conscious thoughts are negative too
not just the subconscious the conscious
thoughts are negative you telling
yourself that you can't do something and
you're not not good enough and then 95%
are the same as yesterday that we've
just creating this this Loop this
negative thinking Loop you've got your
bis Dev show and the point of bis Dev
show is to bring ideal clients on if you
don't think they're an ideal client or
they could refer ideal clients to you
then they're not on the show I again the
light bulb on this morning was
to uh pick entrepreneurs choose
entrepreneurs come on to
entrepreneurship show and in our mind uh
well in my mind entrepreneurs would
probably watch it because I'm talking to
entrepr entrepreneur so yeah I I'm I I
really my mind is really shifted yeah
but they're coming on and just listen to
somebody else's story that doesn't why
would I then hire you I don't know
you're just Larry King asking questions
you're a great question asker right okay
but I'm not hiring you for that
so unless your goal is to be an MC or to
host shows or something else then then
that's a different model right but if
like I'm a coach and I want to sell more
coaching Services then that that's a
better model so you're bringing people
if they don't if they're either not an
ideal client meaning they have a
business and they can afford your
services like if it's a brand new
startup and they're dead broke it's not
ideal client because they can't afford
you so ideal clients or referral
partners lawyers accountants those kinds
of people who deal with entrepreneurs
all day long like if you have the right
lawyer on and they love you they could
be referring every client I'm the kind
of person who likes to write things down
I'm the I'm the kind of person who has
when I have an idea whether it's 2:00 in
the morning or or you know 3: at night
or whatever it is when I have an idea I
want to write it down I feel like unless
I can get it out of my head and now I
tend to just send myself an email and
write an Evernote until I get it out of
my
head I I'm I'm unset I feel like I'm
going to forget the idea and it's
something that I've wrestled with this
message of you know maybe I'm just
knocking around anything down and the
best ideas that I have will just
continue to come back and come back and
come back and those are the ones that I
should run with and if I look at how
many times I actually look over that
Evernote file it's pretty slim and I
feel like I kind of do it anyway where
the best ideas come back to me over and
over again and that's what I run with
but I haven't fully embraced it maybe
it's had a fear of of losing a great
idea and every now and then when I look
through the notes something does come
back and I end up running with it and I
I fear that I may have forgotten if I
didn't write it down and I could have
missed a big chunk of a big project I'm
working on but maybe that's an
irrational fear I don't know this is
something that I want to play with more
I do know that when I was thinking about
my one word of believe that's been the
foundation for this Channel and a lot of
the you know work that I do when I first
thought about it I felt like it was too
big I felt like it wasn't the right one
for for me I felt like uh I felt like it
was hard to live up to and the more I
slept on it the more time went on the
more you know I experimented with it the
more it felt right and every passing day
that big idea just stuck with me more
and more and more until I embraced it
fully and it became the basis of this
Channel and and my website and all the
work that I do so I think there's
something there I feel like I don't do a
good enough job on it and I wonder if it
might be worth an experiment for a week
to not write any anything down and just
trust that the Big Ideas will stay there
that's an interesting one I'm gonna
think on that I'm not going to write it
down I'm gonna think on that we often
judge ideas too early you look at the
nft market right nfts are going to the
moon it's amazing you know Bard a Krypto
Punk let's go like wag me you know all
of this right uh and then you know that
was that was the that was the hopium at
the time and now it crashed and you know
a lot of people are negative but it's
this isn't the final nfts are are going
to happen everybody will have a wallet
everybody will have whether we even call
them nfts or something else in the
future like the blockchain is undeniable
it will happen everything will be on the
blockchain everything everything we do
will be on the
blockchain so what we see right now as
much as there's pessimism and negativity
this is not the final thing and so I see
I look at the same thing with the
ification system they're looking for
ways to make money and they're looking
for ways to combat a lot of the the fake
and the the
copy but this me this is not an elegant
solution either what they've done is not
elegant and so it will be fixed and
somebody will fix it whether it's
whether it's Instagram whether it's Tik
Tok whether it's Elon Musk again whether
it's some new social media site that
pops up comes out of nowhere you know
whether it's you look at how quickly GPT
came out of nowhere
and just popped hard like maybe that's
the next social network that pops hard
and figures out verification as well so
it's we're just I I don't want to judge
is it great no but I'm also judging an
unfinished product it's like if you gave
me your book that's half-written and say
Andre is like this is not very good well
it's half written so we can't judge it
something else will come from it I don't
know who solves the problem but somebody
will solve that problem hey if you're
present-minded you're going to be a lot
happier you're going to be a lot more
focused right if you're just thinking
about what you should have done or what
might happen to you you're not actually
able to be productive and get stuff out
right now in the present and so the the
job becomes how do I stay present and I
think a lot of that is accomplished
through meditation for most people if
you're if you're in a state of stress
thinking about the regret of the past or
anxiety about the future I think
meditation can be incredibly helpful to
help you get back to present even just
focusing on your breath breathe in
breathe out even something as simple as
back can help calm you down and get you
back to the present moment which then
allows you to be able to be productive
uh solve the problem be happy because
you're being more present so for me
that's actually quite easy I'm in the
present uh a lot more than anywhere else
and I used to think it as a negative a
friend of mine used to make fun of me
for having a bad memory like he such a
bad memory it's like and I later
realized I I don't have a bad memory I I
one remember what's important to me but
two not living in the past like I'm I
don't care about what happened I'm
looking at right now today I don't know
what day it is I don't know what day it
is I don't know I I I know it's 2022 and
recording this uh I'd have to think
about what month it is I don't know what
I'm doing after recording this video I
don't know what I did yesterday I don't
know what I'm doing tomorrow let alone
once I press stop on this video I am
here with you this is this is my entire
attention is making this video right now
that's it this is this is the Pres
present moment for me and what I've
discovered is this is
meditation at least the the the portion
of it where you're getting back to
present moment if that's one of the main
benefits of meditation then this is
meditation for me I'm only in the
present moment right now being here
talking with you guys and that's it and
I realize that most of my life is lived
like that yes I love planning for where
I'm going to go but most of my time
isn't spent in planning it's in in
executing in doing and I have to look at
my calendar to see what I'm doing
tomorrow or what I'm doing when somebody
asks me on a Wednesday what's your
weekend going to look like weekend I
don't even know what I'm doing in the
next hour let alone what I'm doing this
weekend and when people ask me on a
Monday how was your weekend like I don't
know that was that was that was
yesterday that was two days ago I'm I
got stuff to do right now I'm working on
my life right now and and not just work
even just enjoying even just life even
just me spending time with with my wife
or my son or on a trip it's like let's
enjoy this moment where we're at right
now and so if that's
you I would introduce the idea of hey
that's a different perspective shift
like maybe you are meditating right now
and you might be over judging yourself
cuz if you're in the present that's one
of the biggest benefits for imposter
syndrome honestly um there's two things
that I'll do one is remember who you're
focused on serving right we're so
worried about trying to be someone that
we're not and who might judge us and who
might comment on your video or whatever
it was something nasty uh but focus on
who you're serving who you are serving
like somebody needs your message today
you've got a message you've been through
something you have advice to share
somebody needs that and focus on who
that person is and it may not be a
million people it may just be eight
people who watch your video but for one
person that might be a life like your
message might be the life-changing
message that they need today and so
focus on that when you're out there
creating and two the other thing I find
helpful is imagine you're talking to to
younger you so when we get suck in
impostor syndrome we think of oh if you
look at Angela who's hosting her own
show like well but I'm not Larry King or
I'm not Oprah or I'm not whoever and we
let that be the reason why we don't
start whereas think about who you used
to be so for me the most painful point
in my life was 19 when I quit on my
business partner and so I go back to
think can I help 19-year-old Evan if I
was gonna sit on a park bench and talk
to 19y old Evan would I have something
that I could say and yeah of course of
course I could help I may not believe I
can help a million people but I believe
I can help younger me and same thing for
you you may not feel like you can help
tons of people you have imposter
syndrome about that but if you think
back to who you used to be think about
who you were five years ago you from
five years ago would listen to you today
and they may not listen to Evan
Carmichael or Oprah or whoever but
they'll listen to you and
so if you you can have a message for
younger you well there's millions of
people who currently are younger you and
they're struggling and they need you and
just I don't know just the way that that
is framed for me
gets me out of my way and forces me to
get into action mode they're both an
angle of service and I'm always going to
lean on service one is you're thinking
about the people who you can help and
two is you think back to younger you and
recognize that you could help younger
you and there are millions of people
right now who are younger you and they
need your help so it's time to go
through I want to hit more people I want
to serve more people like people I want
to spread the message of believe and
we're we're the Wonder is like it's so
so possible and people need this so much
and like how do I make that happen what
is it that people need that you are
bringing to them what is the problem
that you were solving and for who yeah I
think the biggest problem Humanity faces
is a lack of
belief I think in themselves in
themselves yeah like I think whatever
cancer should have been solved a decade
ago but the woman who would have solved
cancer is a manager at KPMG doing a job
she needs because she never believed in
herself enough right that's my like we
solve solve self-belief you solve every
other problem in the world I have a bias
towards entrepreneurs because that's who
I love helping the most so that would be
like helping entrepreneurs believe
themselves more not that you know
teachers and government and whoever else
can't do it and then your background is
like corporate stuff as well so like
great corporations have a huge role to
play I just default to entrepreneurs but
the problem I'm trying to solve is
helping people believe in themselves
more I think the way to do that is
content at scale people get to learn
from you today and learn to have more
self-belief even though like one-on-one
time with you would be insanely
expensive but my journey hopefully they
can learn a little bit as well through
this session so that's what I'm trying
to solve and for who do you have any
tips for creators that are starting out
on the platform and are looking to build
their audience organically oh yeah yeah
no no I'm I'm answering the question
okay the thing
is you need to open your heart to
people ah so I asked you a heart
question mhm and you
shut it down and move back to head right
cuz you said I'm on I want to document
my self Lov Journey that's why I'm doing
my house and my workout you said I want
to document my self- love Journey so I
asked you well where you struggle with
self- love that's a that's a heart
opening
opportunity and then you went to well
I've I've grow I've I've fixed a lot and
I'm I'm much more and I don't really
struggle with that anymore okay cool and
maybe you don't awesome but where do you
struggle mhm cuz if you're telling the
stories about 17-hour days and photo
shoots and it's like the Glam life cool
but it's not really
relatable so what are you struggling
with what's the negative voice in your
mind cuz you're you're you're you're
going to your part Fierce badass going
to show up and crush and want to change
the world right that's in you and then
you're also insecure and self-doubt and
like is this even worth it and when is
it going to happen for me and like all
of those emotions too and all of us are
yeah but that's the heart stuff that if
you can figure out how to dive into that
stuff on a video people will then start
to love you and feel connected to you
and you're still badass Fierce chasing
down your goals so showing all if you're
writing songs with your head and not
your heart it's not going to
win yeah if you go into a studio think
okay what is a hit song going to be and
let me just copy whoever and this is the
track versus no I have something to say
this is what's on my heart like those
will be the better songs songs
vulnerability yeah and so if you're
already doing that in your art now it's
bringing that to just a new form of art
okay and what you want is people to
actually join you the language you use
is great I'm on my journey of self-love
and if you want to swap that out for
something else cool but you take people
on the journey then they want to join
with you on the journey but you have to
let them in not just kind of watching
from the
outside to see 10 more amazing rules for
me check the video right there next to
me I think you'll love it continue to
believe and I'll see you there I think
lack of belief isn't just a problem for
entrepreneurs I think it's just
everybody's problem it's my problem I
think your purpose comes from your pain
so right whatever you struggled the most
with is what you want to help other
people through and because I struggled
so much with believe myself I want to
help other people